questions from an inventor so I got a
couple questions for one of our YouTube
viewers John love you guys who is an
inventor and one of my help to help him
grow his business so I'm going to answer
them in the order that I asked and
hopefully provide value for you guys so
the first one was Evan have a couple
questions for you for certain business
number one patent first or self first
worthy ups and downs this is an easy one
if you have a product and invention that
can be patented then you want to patent
it first before you start selling the
reason is once a product is commercially
available once you're out there selling
it then you can't get a patent on it the
only thing you can patent is
improvements and I made this mistake
with my first company was a software
company we created software and then
launched it and started selling it so to
making some money and then we were
looking at partnerships and investors
and being acquired people ask well do
you have a patent on it and we looked
into it and we actually couldn't get a
patent on it anymore because it was
already released the only thing we get a
patent on was any improvements we made
to the software so any time we added
something new to the software we looked
at getting a patent for that but we
couldn't originally patent our creation
so patent first then sell next question
should i do the website first or make
the product first so obviously you're
going to have to do both my preference
though is to make the website first you
know you want a website that you still
need the product is you're going to have
to have something to sell but marketing
and building momentum is so hard for a
new business that you want to give as
much time as possible to allow momentum
to build up so we create a website and i
would put your ideas on there and have a
way to contact people if it's a
newsletter or whatever it is that people
can sign up for and and get updates and
contribute and as you make improvements
and as a product gets closer to launch
you can update people and get their
feedback if people feel like they're a
part of it and people feel like you know
they're on the inside where they're
learning about this thing before it even
launches they're going to want to share
they're going to feel connected to it
when it does come out they're going to
buy it first they're going to tell their
friends about it so you want to build
that momentum up as soon as possible if
you create the product and spent
all the time creating the product is if
finally it's ready to go and now we're
ready for a website then you're going to
spend so much time just trying to get
the website to have some momentum and
the marketing behind that that you may
get frustrated and a lot of people give
up at that stage so I would start with
the website start building momentum
start getting people to care about it
release updates as a product comes out
and start building your momentum and the
last question was should I learn how to
make my own website or pay people to do
it for us so I hate spending money until
I'm making money I hate spending money
until I'm making money anybody can spend
money right you could take I don't know
how much money you have i'm assuming
money is important to you you don't have
a lot of it and that when you spend
something you have to get a return on it
you know if you had ten thousand dollars
in the bank is it it's the best use of
that to go out and hire web company to
make your website probably not there are
easier ways to get started and i don't
think you learning how to do a website
is the best solution either because then
you're doing stuff that you're not great
at unless you really want to learn web
development is a passion of yours and
you want to dive into it that's a
different story but if it's just I need
a web sites i'm going to learn how to do
it you're not going to be able to be
great by doing things that you're not
great at and you have no interest in
you're going to be great by focusing on
what you're really really good at
obviously at some point we need a
website but you can start starting on
facebook all the tools are there create
a fan page you can have people sign up
right they like the page they get
updates when you're launching something
they can comment on it you can launch
the whole thing on facebook without
spending any money and all the social
tools already built in so i wouldn't
learn how to web code myself and i
wouldn't hire company until you started
making money from the product launch
with facebook launched with something
else use a tool to help you so you're
not spending money believe so jus
watchin liked the video click on the
link to support me in the description
leave a comment let me know what you
think and click on my face subscribe to
the channel thank you so much i'll see
you soon
you